today I'm going to talk about the only
sugar
that won't raise your blood sugar
now I see you're getting pretty excited
about this but before you get too
excited let me explain sugar is
classified in a certain way you have
something called a monosaccharide and
you have disaccharides so let's just
talk about those first so a
monosaccharide is like a one individual
sugar molecule like glucose that would
be a monosaccharide mono meaning one
saccharide means sugar and you also have
another monosaccharide called fructose
and if you combine these different
monosaccharides together you have
different types of sugar
for example table sugar is about 50
percent fructose in 50 glucose and then
you have honey which is 30 percent
fructose and 70 glucose then you have
other sugars like lactose that's like
milk sugar that would be glucose plus
another type of monosaccharide called
galactose and then you have something
called high fructose corn syrup because
it's a combination of glucose and
fructose could range anywhere between
55 to 90 percent fructose and then you
have agave nectar which is combined with
glucose and fructose and fructose in
agave nectar is about 85 percent okay so
it's a lot of fructose then you have
fruit fruit is a combination of glucose
plus fructose but the fructose in fruit
can vary between one percent and 30
percent now you're probably saying like
what would be one percent well it could
be like avocados that would be
considered fruit or maybe olives that
would be considered a fruit very low
sweetness right very low fructose what's
interesting about fructose is that it's
the only sugar that does not activate
the beta cells that's the cells in the
pancreas that release insulin it does
not increase your blood sugars at least
initially when you think about it when
you go to the doctor to get your blood
sugar tested they're not going to be
checking how much fructose that's in the
blood they're going to be checking how
much glucose is in the blood two
completely different monosaccharides and
fructose as a sugar is like twice is
sweet as table sugar and this is another
reason why manufacturing companies might
be putting fructose in our food because
it's just sweeter if you take artificial
sweeteners you're talking about a factor
of like ten thousand to a hundred
thousand times sweeter than sugar so
that's when you tiny bit and humans lack
the enzyme to convert fructose into
glucose so when this was studied and
realized that wow fructose does not
increase your blood sugar they started
to recommend it for diabetics but let me
explain the other half of the story okay
because fructose
follows a different biochemical pathway
than glucose glucose is absorbed by all
the cells but fructose is only really
absorbed by the liver some of it passes
through the intestine because it's not
easily absorbed and it can get into the
colon where your microbes have a frenzy
okay it's kind of like cracked to your
microbes and they will start eating this
up and start growing rapidly and you'll
get a lot of gas and sometimes diarrhea
and a lot of digestive bloating and all
sorts of digestive problems this is why
a lot of people cannot do fruit or just
fructose in general but what about the
stuff that's absorbed to the liver I
want to talk about that because that
fructose in your liver that can be
converted to glucose and stored as
glycogen now if there's enough glycogen
stored in the liver then the body will
instantly start making triglycerides
which are blood fats and cholesterol
it's been well documented that fructose
will make a liver very fatty very
quickly if you consume enough of it
right but we don't consume very much of
it well this is what happens that uh
kids for example 25 of their calories
are in the form of fructose on average
that is crazy so we're consuming a
massive amount of fructose in many
different forms the other problem with
your liver becoming fatty and you
producing all these triglycerides is
that will now create insulin resistance
in a bad way okay more potently than
glucose so now we're going to actually
go right into diabetes a lot quicker and
now the body is going to produce more
insulin indirectly so just because
fructose is low on the glycemic index
and it won't raise your blood sugars it
will do it indirectly and create
problems way worse than glucose
but in a different way I'm sorry you
just kind of got excited there right you
thought maybe you could start consuming
fructose well
you don't want to do that that fructose
will also be converted to uric acid
right so now your gout increases as well
and the more uric acid you have in the
kidney the less vitamin D you're going
to activate because the activation of
vitamin D happens mainly in the kidney
so that could be another problem and
we're going to end up with more
inflammation and also profound
atherosclerosis that's right it leads
right to the clogging or the plaquing of
your arteries now in certain my studies
and by the way like mice and humans
don't have that enzyme to convert
fructose to glucose there is shown a
spike in homocysteine by 72 percent also
you're going to get low leptin levels
and that has everything to do with your
appetite so you're naturally going to
not get satisfied and you're going to
overeat when you consume fructose
probably another reason why they use
high fructose corn syrup and so many
drinks is to get you to drink more and
more because you're not going to be
satisfied given that information you can
have alternative sugars okay these are
called sugar alcohols and for that
information you should watch this video
right here